ALLEN ARCHULETA.
ATKINS BATES [inaudible]
WELL. FOR JUST.
BRADFORD CABRERA CHIANG.
DODD.
TERRORIZER GALGIANI GLAZER GROVE
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG HILL.
WITH SO --
TADA JACKSON JONES.
LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING.
MORLOCK MORALE.
NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO.
ROCK.
RUBIO SKINNER STERN STONE.
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER
WILK.
THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RICE WE WILL BE
LEAD IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN SISTER LIBBY
FERNANDES.
FOUNDER OF MERCY PEDDLERS AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR SKINNER.
AS WE PRAY TODAY IN THANKSGIVING.
FOR MANY DISTINGUISHED WOMEN
LEADERS.
HERE AT OUR STATE.
SENATORS STAFF MEMBERS.
AND WOMEN BEING HONORED HERE
TODAY.
I BEGIN BY QUOTING FROM A SONG
CALLED FOR GOOD.
FROM THE MUSICAL WICKED.
I'VE HEARD IT SAID.
THAT PEOPLE COME INTO OUR LIVES
FOR REASON.
BRING IN SOMETHING WE MUST LEARN.
I KNOW I AM WHO I AM TODAY
BECAUSE OF YOU.
YOU'LL BE WITH ME.
LIKE A HAND PRINT ON MY HEART.
AND NOW WHATEVER WAY OUR STORIES
IN.
I KNOW YOU HAVE A RE WRITTEN
MINE.
AND BECAUSE OF YOU.
I HAVE BEEN CHANGED FOR GOOD.
GOD OF GENEROSITY AND MYSTERY.
WE BLESS AND WE CELEBRATE THE
WOMEN BEING HONORED HERE. FOR
THEIR LIVES F. PASSIONATE AND
DEDICATED SERVICE FOR THE COMMON
GOOD.
BY THEIR COURAGE PATIENCE AND
INCLUSIVE CREATIVITY.
THEY HAVE MODEL FOR ALL OF US
HOW TO LIVE LIVES OF INTEGRITY
AND DEVOTION.
MAY THEY EXPERIENCE THE REWARDS
FOR THEIR WORK.
IN SEEING THE GOOD THEY HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED.
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME
[inaudible]
A MAN [inaudible]
THE CLASS [inaudible]
A FROM [inaudible]
REALLY JUST [inaudible] ONE
INDIVISIBLE.
YEAH ALL THANK YOU SO
.
THE PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR ARE
THERE ANY PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR.
SENATOR DODD AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK SENATOR DODD THE FLOOR'S
YOURS BETTER PRESENT FOR
PURPOSES OF INTRODUCTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I AM
INCREDIBLY HONORED TODAY TO
WELCOME FORMER CONGRESSMAN
UNITED STATES CABINET MEMBER.
NORMAN MINETA IN HIS WIFE DADDY
BUT ADDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
AND THEY'RE HERE TODAY --
TO WITH WITNESS --
ONE OF THEIR VERY VERY GOOD
FRIENDS AND PASS COLLEAGUES THE
OTHER STATE NEWS MY WOMAN OF THE
YEAR RECEIVE THAT HONOR TODAY.
SECRETARY MINETA IS A TRUE
TRAILBLAZER AFTER GRADUATING
FROM UC BERKELEY IN SERVING IN
THE UNITED STATES ARMY.
MISTER MINETA BEGAN HIS
POLITICAL CAREER ON THE SAME AS
A CITY COUNCIL AND THAT IS MAYOR
OF SAN IS A BEFORE HE WAS
ELECTED TO THE UNITED STATES.
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
AMONG HIS MANY ACHIEVEMENTS
DURING HIS TWENTY YEAR CAREER IN
THE HOUSE MISTER MINETA CO
FOUNDED THE CONGRESSIONAL ASIAN
PACIFIC AMERICAN CAUCUS.
IN SERVICE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN TWO THOUSAND HE WAS APPOINTED
SECRETARY OF COMMERCE BY
PRESIDENT CLINTON IN THE TWO
THOUSAND ONE HE WAS APPOINTED
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION BY
PRESIDENT BUSH.
SECRETARY MINETA WENT ON TO
BECOME THE LONGEST SERVING
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION IN
U. S. HISTORY IN A TWO THOUSAND
SIX HE WAS AWARDED THE
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF FREEDOM.
FOR HIS YEARS OF PUBLIC SERVICE.
THE MINETA TRANSPORTATION
INSTITUTE AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY AND THE NORMAN MINETA
SAN JOSE INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT
BEAR HIS NAME.
AS A TESTAMENT TO HIS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING SECRETARY
AND MRS MADE OUT OF VERY WARM.
CENTER WELCOME TO A GREAT MAN.
A GREAT PUBLIC SERVANT AND HIS
PARTNER.
THANK YOU FOR GRACING US WITH
YOUR PRESENCE HERE TODAY
.
AND STILL ARGUING FOR HIS
BECAUSE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US CONGRESSMAN MINETA.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR [inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE
TO SENATE THIRD READING TO TAKE
UP SENATE RESOLUTION.
EIGHTEEN SENATOR LEYVA.
BUT BEFORE WE PROCEED I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR SPECIAL
GUEST FOR TODAY'S EVENT OUR
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR A LANEY KUNO
LOOKED AT THE LOCK IS SKEWS ME.
AN INVITE HER.
IN ONE MINUTE
.
WELL COLLEAGUES AT ME --
REPEAT THAT --
WE WILL MOVE WITHOUT OBJECTION
TO SENATE THIRD READING TO TAKE
UP SENATE RESOLUTION.
EIGHTEEN BUT BEFORE WE PROCEED I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR
SPECIAL GUEST FOR TODAY'S EVENT
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA A LANEY KUNO
LOCKERS.
AND INVITE HER TO SAY A FEW
WORDS MADAM LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON'S
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT PRO
TEM WHAT AN HONOR AND PRIVILEGE
TO BE HERE WITH YOU TODAY
ESPECIALLY IN THE PRESENCE.
OF CALIFORNIA'S OWN SECRETARY
MINETA.
I IT IS A GREAT HONOR TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY AS WE HONOR
CALIFORNIA'S WOMEN OF THE YEAR.
I AM ESPECIALLY PROUD OF THE
HONOREE AT FROM MY OFFICE EMILY
HINTON WHO IS A STUDENT AT THE
NUMBER STATE UNIVERSITY.
SHE IS THE STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
AND THE FIRST SS USE STUDENT AND
FIRST WOMAN FROM SS YOU EVER TO
HOLD THAT POSITION.
LIKE SO MANY WOMEN LEADERS.
EMILY HAS OVERCOME SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES IN HER LIFE INCLUDING
A SUMMER WHEN SHE WAS TAKING
CLASSES IN PHILOSOPHY AND
POLITICAL SCIENCE.
SERVING AS PRESIDENT OF THE
STUDENT BODY AND DURING THAT
SUMMER.
SADLY TRAGICALLY SLEEPING IN HER
CAR.
AS EMILY MET HER OWN CHALLENGES
SHE NEVER STOPPED FIGHTING TO
IMPROVE CONDITIONS FOR ALL
STUDENTS ON CMPUS INCLUDING BY
OPENING A FOOD PANTRY ON HER
CAMPUS IT'S THE NUMBER STATE.
HOMELESSNESS AND FOOD AND
SECURITY ARE TRAGICALLY MORE
COMMON THAN EVER ON CAMPUSES A
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND AS WE IN SACRAMENTO WORK TO
IMPROVE CONDITIONS FOR STUDENTS
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
STUDENTS THEMSELVES.
ARE WORKING HARD TO MAKE THINGS
BETTER.
IN SEVENTEEN NINETY TWO THE
MOTHER OF FEMINISM MARY
WOLLSTONECRAFT SAID.
I DO NOT WISH FOR WOMEN TO HAVE
POWER OVER MEN.
JUST OVER THEMSELVES.
AS THE WOMEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE KNOW ALL TOO
WELL.
THE ONLY WAY WE CAN ASSURE
CONTROL OVER OURSELVES IS BY
HAVING EQUAL REPRESENTATION IN
THE HALLS OF POWER WITHIN OUR
DEMOCRACY.
SO AS WE RECOGNIZE LEADERS FROM
AROUND CALIFORNIA TODAY HERE IN
OUR STATE CAPITAL LETTERS ALSO
RECOMMIT OURSELVES TO FIGHTING
FOR THE EQUAL REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN.
IN ELECTED OFFICE AND IN THE
HALLS OF POWER EVERYWHERE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
THE FIRST WOMAN LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR OF THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR WHICH WE ARE ALL
VERY PROUD [inaudible]
SENATOR LEYVA.
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP THE
S. R. EIGHTEEN WHICH IS FILE
ITEM SEVEN I AM MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION EIGHTEEN BY
SENATOR LEYVA RELATIVE TO
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH SENATOR
LABEL THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AS A CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION EIGHTEEN PROCLAIMING
MARCH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
DURING THIS MONTH WE PAY TRIBUTE
TO THE COUNTLESS AMAZING WOMEN
THAT HAVE MADE HIS STORE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE GROWTH AND
STRENGTH OF OUR NATION AND
PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN
SHAPING THE ECONOMIC.
CULTURAL AND SOCIAL FABRIC OF
OUR SOCIETY.
HISTORY PROVES THAT WOMEN HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO EVERY MOVEMENT OF
SOCIAL CHANGE BY WORKING BOTH
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF THE HOME.
WOMEN HAVE FOUGHT FOR AND LEAD
IN THE SUFFRAGE EQUAL RIGHTS
AMOUNTS OF PATIENT LABOR UNION
ORGANIZING THE CIVIL RIGHTS AND
MORE RECENTLY IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND ASSAULT WITH THE ME TOO WE
SAID ENOUGH AND TIME'S UP
MOVEMENTS.
YET DESPITE DECADES OF WOMEN
STILL FACE DISPARITIES ON A
RANGE OF ISSUES FROM ECONOMIC
SECURITY TO HEALTH LIMITED
ACCESS TO LEADERSHIP POSITIONS.
ALL WITHIN THEIR PROFESSIONS
WOMEN AROUND THE WORLD ARE ALSO
STILL FISHING FACING ISSUES OF
OX OCCUPATIONAL SEX SEGREGATION.
AND GENDER WAGE GAP WHICH REMAIN
EVEN MORE PRONOUNCED FOR WOMEN
OF COLOR. FOR EXAMPLE ALL THE
WOMEN COMPRISE 51% OF THE US
POPULATION WOMEN ACCOUNT FOR
JUST OVER 5% OF CHIEF EXECUTIVES
AMONG THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES.
51% OF THE POPULATION BUT ONLY
5% OF US ARE IN THE C. SUITE
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
ACCORDING TO THE MOUNT SAINT
MARY'S UNIVERSITY THE ANNUAL
REPORT OF THE STATUS OF WOMEN
AND GIRLS IN CALIFORNIA WOMEN
EARNED SEVENTY EIGHT CENTS FOR
EACH.
DOLLAR EARNED BY WHITE MEN IS
THAT AMAZING TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE STILL ONLY EARNS
SEVENTY EIGHT CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR.
AND EVEN LESS FOR WOMEN OF COLOR
WITH ASIAN AMERICAN WOMEN
EARNING SEVENTY FIVE CENTS
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN EARNING
FIFTY NINE CENTS AND LATINOS
EARNING FORTY TWO CENTS.
WOMEN INFLUENCE THE ECONOMY AS
WORKERS CONSUMERS AND DECISION
MAKERS FOR BOTH OUR FAMILIES AND
OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHETHER IT'S IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY OR IN THE DATABASE
SUCCESSES OF OUR FAMILIES FAR
TOO OFTEN WOMEN IN PARTICULAR
WOMEN OF COLOR ARE THE HIDDEN
FIGURES AND ARE HIDDEN HEROES.
HEROES LIKE CATHERINE JOHNSON
DOROTHY VON AND MERRY JACKSON
WHO HELPED PUT A MAN ON THE MOON.
CATHY WILLIAMS WHO FOUGHT IN THE
CIVIL WAR BY POSING AS A MAN AND
ALICE MARBLE.
WHO AFTER RETIRING AS THE BEST
TENNIS PLAYER IN THE WORLD SPIED
ON THE **** DURING WORLD WAR?
TWO S. R. EIGHTEEN HIGHLIGHTS
THESE TRAILBLAZING WOMEN OF THE
PAST AND THE AMAZING WOMEN OF
THE PRESENT INCLUDING THE MANY
WOMEN CATALYSTS FOR THE CHANGE
IN OUR RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS.
SO LET US TODAY CELEBRATE
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH AND THE
GREAT WOMEN THAT CONTINUE TO
STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
DEBATE IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE [inaudible]
CENTER JACKSON.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE ON BEHALF OF
THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CARCASS.
TO SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION.
MANY OF YOU HAVE EITHER.
HAD A JEWISH MOTHER OR KNOWN A
JEWISH.
OR WISHES THEY HAD OR IN SOME
CASES WISHES THEY HADN'T.
OF I DID AND VERY PROUD TO SAY.
JEWISH WOMEN HAVE BEEN IN THE
FOREFRONT OF SO MANY OF THE
CHANGES IN SO MANY THE CRITICAL
ISSUES FACING OUR NATION AND OUR
WORLD.
ADD UP HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
WE NOW HAVE THIRTY SIX WOMEN
MEMBERS.
IN OUR WOMEN'S CAUCUS FIVE OF
WHOM ARE ALSO MEMBERS OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS AND WE KNOW THE
JEWISH TRADITION IS RICH WITH
POWERFUL FEMALE LEADERS.
AND IN OF IN FACT IN A COUPLE
WEEKS WE WILL BE CELEBRATING THE
HOLIDAY OF PURIM WHICH
CELEBRATES QUEEN ESTHER.
A WOMAN WHO USED HER COURAGE AND
HER GUILE TO AVERT A GENOCIDE OF
THE JEWISH PEOPLE SOME TWO
THOUSAND YEARS AGO.
MORE RECENTLY WOMEN LIKE EMMA
LAZARUS.
WHOSE WORDS ARE ENGRAVED ON THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY.
GIVE ME YOUR TIRED YOUR POOR
YOUR HUDDLED MASSES YEARNING TO
BREATHE FREE.
REPRESENTING THE IMMIGRATION OF
SO MANY DIFFERENT CULTURES AND
RELIGIOUS TRADITIONS AND OTHER
ETHNICITIES TO AMERICA GIVE THEM
ALL TO US BECAUSE WE WILL
EMBRACE THEM AS ONE AMERICA.
AND THEN GOLDEN MY YEAR.
THE WORLD'S FOURTH AND ISRAEL'S
FIRST FEMALE PRIME MINISTER.
THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICE THE
NOTORIOUS ROOF BETTER GINSBURG
ONE OF MY HEROES.
THE NOTORIOUS RBG.
WHO WON SAIDWE WILL HAVE A
QUALITY?
WHEN THERE ARE?
NINE THINK ABOUT THAT.
AND OF COURSE EACH OF THESE
WOMEN PERSISTED IN THEIR FIGHT
FOR JUSTICE PUSH BOUNDARIES
SPOKE TRUTH TO POWER.
AND RESHAPE THE COURSE OF
HISTORY.
THE JEWISH CAUCUSES COMMITTED TO
CELEBRATING THE CONTEMPORARY
WOMEN JEWISH LEADERS WHO ARE
CHANGING OUR SURE OLD WORLD.
AND OUR BROTHERS AND OUR SISTERS
FROM ALL DIFFERENT WALKS OF LIFE
AS WE CELEBRATE THE DIVERSITY
THAT MAKES THIS COUNTRY AND THIS
WORLD SO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS I SAY ON BEHALF OF OUR
CAUCUS AND OUR FEARLESS LEADER
CONGRATULATIONS THE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THE HONOREES WHO ARE
HERE TODAY.
YOU WOULD MAKE MY MOTHER MY
JEWISH MOTHER.
WITH THAT I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AM I
AM PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF SR
EIGHTEEN AND I STAND IN SUPPORT
OF WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
ALL OF THE WOMEN IN THIS RUMOR
HERE BECAUSE OF THE HARD WORKING
WOMEN.
HISTORY MAKERS THAT HAVE GONE
BEFORE US AND WE'VE BEEN ALLOWED
THE HONOR TO STAND ON THEIR
SHOULDERS.
THERE ARE ABOUT FOUR THERE ARE
FOUR SKIS ME THREE OUT OF FOUR
AT LEGISLATIVE LEADERS IN THIS
CAPITAL ARE WOMEN.
THE SENATE PRO TEM MENTIONED
THAT THIS MORNING.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT IT DIDN'T
TAKE US A LONG TIME TO GET HERE
THAT'S EVIDENT AS YOU WALK DOWN
THIS HALLWAY BEHIND ME AND YOU
SEE ALL THE PICTURES OF MEN AND
THEN BAM.
SENATOR TONI ATKINS THE FIRST
FEMALE TO HOLD THIS PRESTIGIOUS
POSITION IN THIS CHAMBER.
WE HAVE WOMEN HAVE EARNED OUR
WAY HERE BY HARD WORK AND
PERSEVERANCE WERE VALUABLE IN
THE WORKPLACE WERE VALUABLE IN
THE POLITICAL ARENA IN IN THE
INDUSTRIAL PART OF THE WORLD.
A ONE OF OUR OF OUR FIRST WOMAN
PRO TIM IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE
FROM THE APPALACHIAN MOUNTAINS
TO SERVING IN THE SAN DIEGO CITY
COUNCIL AND THEN BEING ELECTED
IN THE ASSEMBLY IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TEN AND NOW SENATOR ATKINS.
HAS FOUGHT TO BE HERE AND IS ARE
SENATE PRO TEM AND LEADS THIS
CHAMBER WITH STIFF WITH
DISTINCTION.
I HAVE A SIMILAR STORY WHEN
SENATOR RECKONS AND I TALK --
WERE SIMILAR BUT IN BOTH ENDS OF
OUR LIFE IN.
DURING MY YOUTH I WAS NOT A VERY
VERY GOOD I WAS IN A VERY GOOD
STUDENT OR A VERY GOOD PERSON.
AFTER SERVING MY TIME IN
JUVENILE HALL THE MOM.
I JOIN UNITED STATES MILITARY I
SERVED OVERSEAS AT HEADQUARTERS
COMPANY FIFTH CORPS IN FRANKFORT
GERMANY AND THAT SERVICE HAS
ALLOWED ME TO BE THE FIRST
FEMALE EVER VETERAN EVER ELECTED
TO THIS BODY.
AND WHEN I LOOK AT THE MY MOM
WHO IS THE DRIVING FORCE IN ME
MY DAD LEFT MY MOM HAD FIVE KIDS
THE YOUNGEST BEING ONE YEAR OLD.
AND SHE WORKED IN THE FIELDS IN
THE SHEDS SHE WENT BACK TO
SCHOOL AT THIRTY YEARS OLD TO
GET HER HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
AND THEN SHE GOT AN INSURANCE
LICENSE LICENSE AND SHE WAS ONE
OF THE FIRST FEMALE WOMEN TO
EVER BE AN INDEPENDENT AGENT FOR
FARMERS INSURANCE.
LIKE THE WOMEN THAT HAVE GONE
BEFORE US US IN THIS CHAMBER
THAT WILL GO BEFORE THE NEXT
GENERATION OF YOUNG LADIES THAT
ARE COMING UP.
WE STOOD ON THEIR SHOULDERS AND
NOW WE HOPE THAT THEY WILL STAND
ON OUR SHOULDERS.
I'VE LISTED SOME WOMEN HERE IN
NINETEEN SIXTEEN JEANNETTE
RANKIN OF MONTANA WAS THE FIRST
WOMAN ELECTED TO SERVE IN THE
UNITED STATES HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
IN NINETEEN THIRTY TWO AMELIA
EARHART BECAME EARHART BECAME
THE FIRST WOMAN TO FLY SOLO
ACROSS THE ATLANTIC.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR MARGARET
CHASE SMITH WAS THE FIRST WOMAN
NOMINATED BY ANY POLITICAL MAJOR
POLITICAL PARTY FOR PRESIDENT.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE SANDRA
DAY O'CONNOR WAS APPOINTED BY
THE PRESIDENT REAGAN TO SERVE AS
THE FIRST WOMAN JUSTICE IN THE
SUPREME COURT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE JANET
RENO BECAME THE FIRST WOMAN U.
S. ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I'M ALSO IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE SHEILA WHIM WINDOW BECAME
THE FIRST FEMALE SECRETARY OF
THE UNITED STATES ARMY OUR SKIS
WITH FOR SECRETARY THE UNITED
STATES MILITARY WHO LED THE
UNITED STATES AIRFORCE.
I'M DURING THAT TIME TODAY WOMEN
ARE MAKING HISTORY ACROSS THIS
NATION AND ACROSS THE STATE AND
BUILDING I'M MORE IN THIS
BUILDING MORE THAN EVER BEFORE.
WE HAVE THE YOUNGEST FEMALE --
ON THE FLOOR TODAY THE YOUNGEST
FEMALE TO AND I'M HONORED TO
SHARE KERN COUNTY WITH HER.
WE ALSO HAVE IN OUR PRESENCE --
I HOPE I GET THIS RIGHT WE HAVE
THE FIRST FEMALE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR CALIFORNIA A LANEY
GOOGLE GOOGLE LAKIS.
NO COULD A LOT GUESTS.
I LOVE THE COMMERCIAL BY THE WAY
IT WAS GOOD.
I CHALLENGE THE WONDERFUL LADIES
IN THIS CHAMBER THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
YOUNG WOMEN COMING UP BEHIND
DOES HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
STAND STRONG ON OUR SHOULDERS OF
WE HAVE STOOD STRONG ON ALL
THOSE WOMEN THAT HAVE CAME
BEFORE US.
AND THE HISTORY MAKERS AND I
BELIEVE WE HAVE HISTORY MAKERS
IN THIS BUILDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR GROVE IF I COULD
REMIND TO AT LEAST ON THE FLOOR
THERE REALLY IS NOT SUPPOSED TO
BE ANY APPLAUSE BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE THOSE.
ELOQUENT COMMENTS --
I'M SORRY TO BE THE THE WET
NOODLE HERE BUT IF WE COULD HAVE
THAT DECORUM IT WOULD BE MOST
APPRECIATED IS THERE ANY OTHER.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
LABOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
FOR WOMEN EVERYWHERE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS.
I BATES.
I FELL.
I BORDERS.
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I DRAWS THEM [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER.
AYE GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HELLO.
AYE HUESO.
I HER DAUGHTER. FIVE JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible] FIVE LEYVA
[inaudible] FIVE MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING. FIVE MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
I BROWN [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I CAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROB [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible] FIVE NUMBER.
I LIKE HOUSING.
I WIENER.
I WILK.
HI I JUST THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW RECESS THE
REGULAR SESSION AND RECOGNIZE
OUR TWENTY NINETEEN WOMEN OF THE
YEAR HONOREES
.
WHY DO I FEEL LIKE THIS IS A A
COLLEGE GRADUATION WITH ALL THE
PEOPLE UP IN THE STANDS READY TO
TAKE THEIR PHOTOS [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY [inaudible]
PLEASE BEGIN.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT TO LISA
WIKI SCHAFFNER ESCORTED BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
LISA SCHAFFNER HAS DEVOTED HER
LIFE TO PUBLIC SERVICE SERVING
AS MAYOR OF HEALDSBURG AND IN
HER CURRENT ROLE AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE JOHN JORDAN
FOUNDATION WHICH HAS DONATED
MILLIONS TO HELP THOUSANDS OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH AND
NEED.
MAY SHOPPERS TIRELESS LEADERSHIP
HAS ENSURED INCREASED ACCESS TO
EDUCATION AND HEALTH SERVICES
FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT THREE
HEATHER STANTON ESCORTED BY
SENATOR DODD.
HEATHER STANTON IS A DEDICATED
RETIRED PUBLIC SERVICE SERVANT
WITH.
THEIR OVER THIRTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WITH VARIOUS
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
HER WORK ON THE GROWING ISSUES
FACED BY TODAY'S ELDER
POPULATION HAS RESULTED IN MAJOR
CHANGES IN HOW CRITICAL SENIOR
SERVICES ARE BEING DELIVERED IN
NAPA AND SOLANO COUNTY IS.
WE WE CAN APPLAUD THIS
PARTICULAR PART OF THE THANK YOU.
I DON'T WANT TO BE THERE WITH
BLANKETS THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
HERE WE GO FROM SENATE-DISTRICT
FOR CASEY HATCHER ESCORTED BY
SENATOR NIELSEN.
CASEY HATCHER BUTTE COUNTY'S
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT MANAGER AND
PUBLIC INFORMATION OFFICER HAS
BEEN AT THE HEART OF THE
COMMUNITY'S RESPONSE TO THE
CAMPFIRE SHE HAS HELPED TO
INFORM THE PUBLIC WITH ACCURATE
AND TIMELY INFORMATION DESPITE
THE CHAOS OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
DEVASTATING FIRE.
HER DEDICATION TO THIS COMMUNITY
IS UNWAVERING [inaudible]
CONGRATULATIONS.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT FIVE CHERYL
MCFALL.
ESCORTED BY SENATOR GALGIANI.
CHERYL HAS LIVED AND WORKED IN
MANTECA FOR THE LAST THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AND HAS BECOME A CONSTANT
FIXTURE IN HER COMMUNITY.
SHE IS HEAVILY INVOLVED IN
POLITICS MENTORING NEW AGENTS TO
BECOME LEADERS.
AND HASTERT SERVED ON SEVERAL
COMMITTEES THAT HAVE RAISED TO
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR
CHARITIES IN THE DISTRICT. FOR
DISTRICT FIVE WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT SIX KIM
WILLIAMS ESCORTED BY SENATOR PAN.
KIM WILLIAMS HAS BEEN THE
DIRECTOR OF THE SACRAMENTO
BUILDING HEALTHY COMMUNITIES
HAVE FOR THE LAST EIGHT YEARS.
PRIOR TO THAT SHE SERVED AS THE
CEO OF THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUBS
OF GREATER SACRAMENTO FOR FOUR
YEARS.
SHE HAS OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE IN COMES FOR YOUTH.
A WARM ROUND OF APPLAUSE PLEASE
FOR KIM WILLIAMS SENATOR PANS
WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT SIX
MARGARET LEON ESCORTED BY
SENATOR GLAZER.
MARGARET LEON OF DUBLIN
CALIFORNIA IS AN ACTIVE MEMBER
OF HER COMMUNITY SHE WAS THE
FOUNDER AND IS CURRENT PRESIDENT
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ASSOCIATION TRI VALLEY CHAPTER.
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
AIMS TO IT ENGAGE ENCOURAGE AND
EMPOWER ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLAND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND CIVIC
AFFAIRS.
AMONG HER MANY ACHIEVEMENTS
MARKET HAS HELP SCHOOLS ORGANIZE
MULTI CULTURAL EVENTS AND TALENT
SHOWS PROMOTED COMMUNITY
AWARENESS OF CITY AND SCHOOL
ISSUES AND HAS HOSTED NATIONAL
NIGHT OUT GATHERINGS.
SHE IS ALSO BROUGHT THE
COMMUNITY TOGETHER TO RECOGNIZE
LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS IN THEIR
EFFORTS BATTLING THE DEVASTATING
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES.
A WARM.
ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
SENATOR GLAZERS WOMAN OF THE
YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT DATE THE
VINO WITCHER ESCORTED BY SENATOR
BOARD JUST.
THE VINO WITCHER IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR MEDICAL OUR REGION
RELIEF I'M MORE.
THE MISSION OF A MORE IS TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH STATUS OF THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
THE VENUS BEGAN HER CAREER IN
MEDICINE IN.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE SINCE
JOINING A MORE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT SHE HAS SUCCESSFULLY
LAUNCHED PROJECTS HERE AND IN
AFGHANISTAN.
A MORE WILL BREAK GROUND THIS
YEAR ON AN ECO FRIENDLY FACILITY
IN THE HEART OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY DESIGNED TO TRANSFORM
HEALTH OUTCOMES THROUGH AN
ALLIANCE OF MEDICAL SOCIAL AND
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT SERVICES.
A WARM ROUND OF APPLAUSE PLEASE
FOR GORGEOUS WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT NINE DIANA
BACK THEN ESCORTED BY SENATOR
SKINNER.
DIANA BACKED IN AS THE FIRST
WOMAN AND THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN TO SERVICE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
OVER HER DISTINGUISHED CAREER AS
A JUDGE LAWYER IN MANAGER SHE
HAS BEEN COMMITTED TO
SAFEGUARDING COMMUNITIES FROM
CRIME AND WORKING ON POSITIVE
OUTCOMES FOR SENIORS AND YOUTH.
A WARM ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY DIANA BACKED
IN SENATOR SCANNERS WOMAN OF THE
YEAR
.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT TEN PARVEEN
AHMADI ESCORTED BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE GATE.
MAHDI HAS BEEN THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF CASTRO VALLEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN PARVEEN AHMADI
STRONG COMMITMENT TO EQUITY AND
HER BELIEF THAT ALL MEANS ALL
HAVE.
BENEFITTED STUDENTS IN THE BAY
AREA FOR THE LAST THIRTY YEARS
SHE BELIEVES IN EMPOWERING
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES AND
BUILDING COMMUNITY.
A WARM WELCOME TO SUPERINTENDENT
AHMADI SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KEYS
WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT ELEVEN
NIKKI TEACHER I'D A COMMA
ESCORTED BY SENATOR WIENER.
NIKKI TEACHER I'D A COMMA HAS
COMMITTED HER LIFE AND CAREER TO
HELPING VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
ESPECIALLY THE TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY WHILE STRIVING TO
CONSTANTLY IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
SAN FRANCISCANS.
TODAY WE RECOGNIZE HER HARD WORK
AND TREMENDOUS CONTRIBUTIONS
THROUGH HER INVOLVEMENT WITH
COUNTLESS ORGANIZATIONS AND
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF HER
COMMUNITY.
A ROUND OF APPLAUSE PLEASE FOR
SENATOR WE DOES.
WOMAN OF THE YEAR NIKKI TEACHER
HIDE A COMMA.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT.
TWELVE KLAUDIA G. CORTADO
ESCORTED BY SENATOR CABALLERO.
CLAUDIA COULD SHADOW IS PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR CALLED VIVA LAS
SALUTE IN MERCED COUNTY.
SHE HAS WORKED FOR THE PAST TWO
DECADES IN THE MANAGEMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION CLAUDIA CONTINUES
HER SERVICE IN MERCED COUNTY
ADVOCATING FOR HEALTHY NUTRITION
AND PHYSICAL ACTIVITY THROUGH
POLICY AND SYSTEM CHANGE.
CONGRATULATIONS TO SENATOR
COUPLE GYROS WOMAN OF THE YEAR
CLAUDIA CORE SHAHDOL.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT THIRTEEN
EMILY EMI THURBER ESCORTED BY
SENATOR HEALTH.
I'M ONLY ME THURBER HAS
DEDICATED A LIFETIME TO PUBLIC
SERVICE AND WOMEN'S LEADERSHIP.
I MEAN WAS PRESIDENT OF THE
SEMPERVIRENS FUND AND THE STATE
THE STATE'S OLDEST LAND TRUST
SERVED ON THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN.
IN THE BOARDS OF THE MID
PENINSULA Y. W. C. A. AND LOS
ALTERS COMMUNITY FOUNDATION SHE
IS A FOUNDING MEMBER MEMBER OF
THE LOS ALTERS WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
CONGRATULATIONS TO EMILY EMI
THURBER SENATOR HILLS WOMAN OF
THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT FOURTEEN
BARBARA JEAN HELL ESCORTED BY
SENATOR TADO.
BARBARA JEAN HELL WAS BORN
INSIDE PAN COMMONWEALTH OF THE
NORTHERN MARIANA ISLANDS IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE TO TWO
WORLD WAR TWO VETERANS.
HER MOTHER ROSEMARY WAS A NAVY
NURSE AND HER FATHER ROBERT WAS
A MARINE CORPS FIRST LIEUTENANT.
BARBER IS MARRIED TO HER COLLEGE
SWEETHEART TERRY NORRIS AND HAS
THREE CHILDREN ARTHUR AND NICK
NELSON AND MARY CATHERINE NORRIS.
AND CONGRATULATIONS TO BARBARA
JEAN HILL SENATOR HER TAUGHT
OWES WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT FIFTEEN
KATHY FORWARD ESCORTED BY
SENATOR ABOUT.
KATHY FORWARD IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS KNOWN
AS NAMI AND SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
NAMI IS A NONPROFIT GRASSROOTS
MENTAL HEALTH ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO BUILDING UP
FAMILIES AND PEOPLE LIVING WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS.
KATHY HAS BEEN COMMITTED TO THE
ISSUE OF MENTAL HEALTH FOR
DECADES AND HAS WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO PROVIDE EDUCATION
ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT TO SENATE
DISTRICT FIFTEENS COMMUNITY.
CONGRATULATIONS TO CAP THE FORD.
SENATOR BELLS WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT.
SEVENTEEN DIANA HE MENACE
ESCORTED BY SENATOR MONNING
DIANA HUMAN AS IS CURRENTLY THE
CAL WORKS EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND HAS WORKED
FOR THE MONTEREY COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
GROWING UP DIANA WORKED AS A
FIELD WORKER WITH HER FAMILY AND
HAS BEEN INSPIRED BY THIS FIRST
HAND EXPERIENCE TO ASSIST THOSE
IN POVERTY.
CONGRATULATIONS DIANA JIMENEZ
SENATOR MORNINGS WOMAN OF THE
YEAR.
FROM.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT EIGHTEEN
DIANA OF HARRISON PHD.
ESCORTED BY SENATOR HERTZBERG.
NEARLY SIXTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
HAVE EARNED THEIR DEGREES AT
SINCE DOCTOR DIANE AFFAIRS AND
BECAME CSU NORTHRIDGE PRESIDENT
IN.
TWENTY TWELVE AS A NATIONAL
HIGHER EDUCATION LEADER DR
HARRISON SERVES ON NUMEROUS
BOARDS INCLUDING THE LOS ANGELES
AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE
WESTERN INTERSTATE COME
COMMISSION FOR HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION
THE RIVER TRANSFORMATIVE
LEADERSHIP CSU AND ADVANCES
SOCIAL MOBILITY FOR ITS NEARLY
FORTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
ELEVATING SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND BEYOND.
CONGRATULATIONS TO PRESIDENT
DIANNE HIRSON SENATOR HERTZBERG
WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
I'M SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY ONE
JUDY A COOPER BURKE AND MASSEY
P. R. P..
ESCORTED BY SENATOR WILK.
JUDY EIGHT COOPER BERG'S THIRTY
YEAR COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING THE
MENTAL AND SOCIAL HEALTH OF
ADULTS AND CHILDREN IN THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY IS UNSURPASSED.
SHE HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY IN THE
COMMUNITY TO ESTABLISH MULTIPLE
PROGRAMS SERVING THE HOMELESS
IMPROVING LOCAL VETERANS
PROGRAMS AND CONTINUES TO
ACTIVELY ADVOCATE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS.
CAN GRADUATION SHOOTING COOPER
BIRDS SENATOR WELLS.
WOMAN OF THE YEAR
.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY TWO
MARQUEE SHEA ESCORTED BY SENATOR
RUBIO.
MARK IS A IS A CLASSICAL VIçT
VIOLINIST IN GENRE DEFYING
VOCALIST WITH THE TWELVE
LANGUAGE THREE AKTIV OPERATIC
RANGE.
SHE IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ARCADIA PERFORMING ARTS
FOUNDATION SHE OVERSEES ALL
ASPECTS OF THE FOUNDATION BUT
HER FAVORITE JOB IS RAISING
MONEY FOR THE FOUNDATION WHICH
GOES TO SCHOLARSHIPS FOR
PERFORMING ARTS STUDENTS IN THE
AREA.
CONGRATULATIONS TO MARQUIS SHAPE
SENATE RUBIO'S WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY
THREE LILIANA ANDRIY ANI
ESCORTED BY SENATOR BROWN.
LEON UNDER JOHNNY WAS BORN AND%
RAISED IN CALI COLOMBIA
IMMIGRATING SHE UNITED STATES IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX SHE IS
CURRENTLY THE OWNER OF ANGEL
JEWELERS A SMALL BUSINESS IN
RANCHO CUCAMONGA.
SHE IS ACTIVE IN THE COMMUNITY
THROUGH BY MEANT WITH A NUMBER
OF LOCAL CHARITIES.
CONGRATULATIONS LEON ADRIANA.
ANDREW YANI SENATOR MORALES
WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY FOUR
ROXANNA DOING YES ESCORTED BY
SENATOR A ROCK SENATOR ONE YES
GREW UP IN EAST LOS ANGELES.
SHE ATTENDED GARFIELD HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATED FROM UCLA AND
IS NOW A TEACHER AT ROOSEVELT
HIGH SCHOOL A TRUE EASDALE LA
CLASSIC.
SHE WAS ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THE RATE RECENT TEACHERS STRIKE
FIGHTING FOR BETTER CONDITIONS
FOR STUDENTS AND TEACHERS IN THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
ROCK SANTA WAS FEATURED IN THE
UNITED TEACHERS LOS ANGELES
STRIKE POSTERS AS THE FACE OF
THE TEACHERS AND LOS ANGELES.
CONGRATULATIONS ROXANA TWENTY
YEARS SENATOR DRAWS SHOWS WOMEN
OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY FIVE
LOUISE DOES THEIR CISCO ESCORTED
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
AS THE ONE HUNDRED AND FIRST
ROSE QUEEN LOUISE DUSTER SISKEL
PURSUED A TRAILBLAZING SOCIAL
AND CIVIC AGENDA.
A SENIOR AT SEQUOIA HIGH IN
PASADENA SHE'S ON THE JUDICIAL
COMMITTEE AND SERVE FOR TWO
YEARS AS A STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENT.
HER RESEARCH IN SPACE BIOLOGY
HAS BEEN FUNDED BY NASA AMES AND
SHE IS CURRENTLY CONDUCTING
BREAST CANCER RESEARCH.
LOUISE ENJOYS READING TRAVELING
AND LAUGHING WITH FRIENDS. TO
SENATOR PORTANTINO'S WOMAN OF
THE YEAR CONGRATULATIONS LOUISE
TESTER CISCO.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY SIX
CATHERINE BAXTER ESCORTED BY
SENATOR ALLEN.
CAPTAIN BAXTER HAS BEEN AN ACT
HAS BEEN ACTIVE IN SERVING THE
SANTA MONICA COMMUNITY SINCE SHE
WAS A STUDENT AT SANTA MONICA
HIGH SCHOOL.
THROUGHOUT HER THIRTY FIVE YEAR
CAREER AS AN EDUCATOR AND
ADMINISTRATOR WITH THE SANTA
MONICA SCHOOL DISTRICT CAPTAIN
HAS CONTINUOUSLY URGE FOR
STUDENTS TO MAKE AN IMPACTFUL
AND LASTING CHANGE IN THE WORLD
THAT WE LIVE IN. ONE EXAMPLE OF
A STUDENT WHO SHE MEANT TOWARD.
AND A HEARTY CONGRATULATIONS. TO
CATHERINE BAXTER SENATOR ALLEN'S
[inaudible]
YEAH.
LEAVE IT TO THOSE RODDY FOLKS
FROM LA.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY
SEVEN LIEUTENANT JENNIFER SEE
TWO ESCORTED BY SENATOR STERN.
LIEUTENANT JENNIFER SEE TWO IS
AN OFFICER AT THE MALIBU LOS
TELLS CHAIR OF STATION
RECOGNIZED FOR HER EXTRAORDINARY
LEADERSHIP AS ACTING CAPTAIN
DURING THE WALLS THE FIRE
HELPING ORGANIZE THE LARGEST
EVACUATION AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY HISTORY.
LIEUTENANCY TO DEMONSTRATED
TIRELESS EMPATHY AND POISE EVEN
ENSURING THAT CHILDREN OF FIRE
AFFECTED FAMILIES RECEIVED
CHRISTMAS PRESENTS.
THANK YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS TO
LIEUTENANT JENNIFER SEE.
TO SENATOR STERN.
WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY NINE
HANNAH GAUGING CAM ESCORTED BY
SENATOR CHIANG.
HANNAH WHY KIM IS A WOMAN WITH A
PASSION FOR SERVICE AFTER
WORKING AS CHIEF OF STAFF AND
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR IN THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS HE
PERSONALLY TRAVEL TO ALL FIFTY
STATES AND US TERRITORIES TO
THANK A THOUSAND KOREAN WAR
VETERANS.
SHE'S A PROUD PASTOR'S KID FROM
DIAMOND BAR CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
CONGRATULATIONS.
JUN CAM SENATOR CHANGE WOMAN OF
THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY
KERRY AND FERAL HINES ESCORTED
BY SENATOR MITCHELL.
KERRY AND FERAL HINES HAS
DEDICATED HER PROFESSIONAL
CAREER THE PUBLIC SERVICE AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR GENDER EQUALITY
ECONOMIC JUSTICE AND THE
PROTECTION OF CIVIL RIGHTS AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES.
SHE IS HELPED WOMEN AND GIRLS
GRASS POWER THROUGH HER
LEADERSHIP AND HARD WORK IN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROMOTE
WOMEN'S EQUALITY IN SOCIETY.
CONGRATULATIONS KERRY AND FERAL
HINES SENATOR MITCHELL'S WOMAN
OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY ONE
ESTELLA A COUP NHà ESCORTED BY
SENATOR ROTH. FOR TWENTY THREE
YEARS A STELLAR KUNYA HAS BEEN
AN ACTIVIST AND EDUCATOR SERVING
AS A POWERFUL ADVOCATE FOR THE
CHICANO LATINO COMMUNITY SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX HER WORK AT
UC RIVERSIDE'S CHICANA STUDENT
PROGRAMS HAS OPENED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOUSANDS AND
CREATED SUPPORT STRUCTURES THAT
HAVE HELPED COUNTLESSSTUDENTS
EARN THEIR COLLEGE DEGREES AND
MOVE ON TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS TO
A STELLAR CORNEA SENATOR ROSS
WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY TWO
CAPTAIN LESLEY MURRAY ESCORTED
BY SENATOR ARCHULETA.
LESLIE MURRAY IS A CAPTAIN WITH
THE DOWNEY POLICE DEPARTMENT
WHERE SHE WAS ORIGINALLY HIRED
AS A RECRUIT.
SHE ROSE THROUGH THE RANKS FIRST
PROMOTED TO SERGEANT AND THEN TO
THE RANK OF LIEUTENANT MOST
RECENTLY LESLIE WAS PROMOTED TO
THE RANK OF CAPTAIN AND
CURRENTLY OVERSEES THE DETECTIVE
BUREAU AND ADMINISTRATION.
CONGRATULATIONS CAPTAIN LESLEY
MARI SENATOR ARCHULETA IS WOMAN
OF THE YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT.
THIRTY FOUR LEAH SMITH ESCORTED
BY SENATOR UMBERG.
WE JUST MET AS A COMMUNITY
MEMBER CATHOLIC WORKER AND
HOMELESS ACTIVIST SHE WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND GRADUATED FROM
UCLA WITH A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN SHE AND
HUSBAND DWIGHT SMITH MOVED TO
THE EYES THEIR HOUSE AND SANTANA
WHICH SERVES AS THEIR HOME AND A
WOMEN'S HOMELESS SHELTER.
THANK YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS
SALINAS.
SENATOR ON BIRDS WOMAN OF THE
YEAR.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY FIVE
MICHELLE SMITH BALLARD ESCORTED
BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
MICHELLE IS THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF COMMUNITY AND CITIZENSHIP FOR
THE TURNER CONSTRUCTION COMPANY
RESPONSIBLE FOR CONSTRUCTING THE
LOS ANGELES RAMS STADIUM AND
INGLEWOOD.
SHE IS THE ONLY WOMAN AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN OVERSEEING A BILLION
DOLLAR STADIUM PROJECT IN THE
NATION.
THE CONSTRUCTION WILL PROVIDE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED ON SITE CONSTRUCTION
JOBS IN INGLEWOOD AND OVER TEN
THOUSAND JOBS BY COMPLETION.
CONGRATULATIONS SENATOR BRADFORD
WOMAN OF THE YEAR MICHELLE SMITH
BALLARD.
CAN GO ROOMS.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY SIX
LISA RODMAN ESCORTED BY SENATOR
BATES.
REPRESENTING THE THIRTY SIX
SENATE DISTRICT.
SENATOR PATRICIA BATES IS PROUD
TO HONOR LISA RODMAN ANSWER
TWENTY NINETEEN WOMAN OF THE
YEAR.
LISA IS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE AGUA HEAVY ON THE
LAGOON FOUNDATION IN CARLSBAD
WHOSE MISSION IS TO PRESERVE THE
LAGOON AS AN ACCESSIBLE AND
HEALTHY WATERSHED.
CONGRATULATIONS TO LISA RODMAN.
SENATOR BATES WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
LA HAS NOTHING ON YOU GUYS.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY
EIGHT D. DEAN ESCORTED BY
SENATOR JONES.
THE RETIRED TWENTY YEAR
PUBLISHER OF THE EAST COUNTY
HERALD THE DEAN AS IT IN IS AN
ADMIRED LEADER WITH AN EXTENSIVE
RECORD OF SERVICE TO EAST SAN
DIEGO COUNTY.
WITH AN INDOMITABLE SPIRIT D.
BATTLES MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS SHE
EDUCATES THE PUBLIC INSPIRES
OTHERS FACING SIMILAR BATTLES
AND EARNED.
THE NATIONAL MS SOCIETY STAR
BOND HERE AWARD.
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANKS TO DE
DEAN.
SENATOR JONES WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
THANKS AND THEN AS PRESIDENT.
WAIT TILL SIX AND THEN ON FROM
SENATE DISTRICT FORTY RHONDA
HUNT PHILLIPS ESCORTED BY
SENATOR HUESO. ONE IS A TRUE
ASSET TO THE FORTY EIGHT STATES
SENATE DISTRICT HER ENDLESS
PROFESSIONAL ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE
MATCHED BY HER MARRIED
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE COMMUNITY.
RHONDA IS A STRONG VOICE FOR
DIVERSITY AND WOMEN IN
LEADERSHIP ROLES I DON'T ROLE
MODEL AND MENTOR FOR ALL WHO
MEET HER.
CONGRATULATIONS TO RONDA HUNT
PHILLIPS CENTER WEST COAST WOMAN
OF THE YEAR. FOR DISTRICT
.
FORTY FROM SENATE DISTRICT
NINETEEN ERICA D. BACK PHD
ESCORTED BY SENATOR JACKSON.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN PRESIDENT
ERICA DE BAC BECAME THE FIRST
WOMAN PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY CHANNEL ISLANDS.
UNDER HER LEADERSHIP THE
YOUNGEST CSU CAMPUS HAS SEEN A
RECORD NUMBER OF APPLICANTS AND
EXPANSION HAS RECEIVED NATIONAL
RECOGNITION FOR ITS EXCEPTIONAL
PROGRAMS AND HAS BECOME A MAJOR
ECONOMIC DRIVER IN THE STATE AND
COMMUNITIES IT SERVES.
CONGRATULATIONS TO SENATOR
JACKSON'S ERICA DE BACK
.
FROM SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY NINE
CHARISMA DAY LOS RAZ ESCORTED BY
SENATOR ATKINS.
CHRIS A LOS RAZ IS A SOCIAL
JUSTICE WARRIOR IN PUBLIC CHILD
WELFARE STARTING AS AN
INVESTIGATOR AND CURRENTLY A
POLICY ANALYST IN COORDINATOR
FOR THE COMMERCIAL SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION OF CHILDREN PROGRAM.
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS SHE HAS
BEEN A THIS LOCALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY WITH A PASSION
FOR GENUINE EMPOWERMENT AND
EQUITY.
CONGRATULATIONS TO PRO TEM.
ATKINS THAT IS MY THE LOS RAYOS
.
EMILY F. HINTON ESCORTED BY
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR KONA LAKIS.
EMILY HINTON A SENIOR AT CINEMA
STATE WAS APPOINTED AS A STUDENT
TRUSTEE TO THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EVEN AS SHE FACED HOMELESSNESS
LIVING OUT OF HER CAR ONE SUMMER
WHILE SERVING AS ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS PRESIDENT.
I'M ONLY WORKS TO INCREASE BASIC
NEEDS RESOURCES INCLUDING FOOD
AND HOUSING SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS
LIKE HER.
EMILY GRADUATES THIS MAY AND
WILL PURSUE A CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE.
CONGRATULATIONS TO LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR MARK IS SAYS WOMAN OF
THE YEAR EMILY AB.
HINTON
.
ROOM SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY
CAMMARATA ESCORTED BY SENATOR
LEYVA.
CAME RUSSIA IS THE CO FOUNDER OF
CONCERN TO NEIGHBORS A
BLOOMINGTON A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION PROMOTING
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT AND
COMMUNITY PARTICIPATION AND
LOCAL SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES.
SHE IS AN ADVOCATE AND CHAMPION
FOR THE VOICELESS PROMOTING A
MORE SUSTAINABLE QUALITY OF LIFE
RESPONSIBLE LAND USE DECISIONS
IMPROVED PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
SENATOR LABELS WOMAN AT THE OH
BOY.
COLLEAGUES WHICH ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WOMEN OF THE
YEAR WHO WERE UNABLE TO ATTEND
SENATOR GROVES WOMAN OF THE YEAR
BEVERLY CAMP.
SENATOR STONE'S WOMAN OF THE
YEAR DARLA TIERNEY BURKETT AND
SENATOR MORE LARKS WOMAN OF THE
YEAR ROBERTA GREENE AHMANSON.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ONE MORE ROUND
OF APPLAUSE FOR THESE
EXTRAORDINARY WOMEN ARE WOMEN OF
THE YEAR
.
FOR TWENTY NINE MEMBERS THE
REGULAR SESSION IS NOW
RECONVENED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL DE BE DEEMED READ
IT MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTION
AND NOTICES ARE THERE ANY.
MOTIONS FOR SENATOR CHANGE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THERE WILL BE
THE ORDER ANY OTHER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
[inaudible] ONE UNDER FILE ITEM
THREE S. C. R..
THIRTEEN THERE WILL BE A PASS ON
FILE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
CENTER CHAIN WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU ONE MORE TIME PLEASE LET'S
MAKE SURE HER MIKE IS ON SO THAT
YOU CAN --
IDENTIFY THE REQUEST SENATOR
CHIANG [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
REQUEST TO MOVE FILE ITEM FOR US
YOU'RE FIFTEEN TO THE INACTIVE
FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THERE WILL BE
THE ORDER.
ANY OTHER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES.
SEEING NONE AND IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR ATKINS OUR PRESIDENT PRO
TEMPORE THE FIRST WOMAN TO BE IN
THAT CAPACITY.
AFTER WOMEN OF THE YEAR.
THE DESK IS CLEAR.
I'M PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND TO ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY I HOPE YOU
ENJOYED IT AS MUCH AS ARE WOMEN
OF THE YEAR DID.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL RECONVENE
AT NINE AM ON THURSDAY THANK YOU.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
MADE WE RECONVENE COLLEAGUES ON
THURSDAY AT NINE A. M..
THERE WILL BE A GROUP PHOTO
COLLEAGUES OUTSIDE THE CHAMBERS
BY THE STAIRCASE IMMEDIATELY
UPON END OF SESSION WHICH IS NOW
IF ANY OF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE THERE WILL BE A
PHOTOGRAPH.
OF ALL COLLEAGUES AND WOMEN OF
THE YEAR OUTSIDE THE CHAMBER
FOURTH WITH